this week conflict zone is in Warsaw
where the Polish government is facing
mounting criticism from the EU over its
record on democracy and human rights my
guest is the Deputy Prime Minister
Matteo Sh Moravia Itsuki there is his
government ready to accept the concerns
voiced by Brussels or continue to reject
them out of hand
[Music]
my tariffs maretskiy
welcome to conflict zone hello nice to
be here with you we've seen some pretty
harsh language between your government
and the EU over your record on democracy
and human rights last month your foreign
minister actually referred to Donald
Tusk president of the European Council
as an icon of evil and stupidity how do
these slanging matches help your
relations with the EU
I think that on both sides the language
is sometimes too strong and sometimes it
does not help in our relationships but
also the asymmetry of perception is a
very important thing we have to do some
changes which in in Germany was done 25
years ago like for instance the
communication of the former deutsches
demokratische republik was was done in
1991 1992 in East Germany and we would
like we would like to do the same here
the EU doesn't seem to see it
they've coded a systemic threat to the
rule of law in Poland this was from the
European Commission but that's very
important and very interesting because
when for instance the in in the Czech
Republic or in in Germany there was this
vetting or verification of of the past
of the professor's or in the in the
academia in the world of academia this
was right when we tried to do the same
in Poland this was not right so let's
let's have the same standards applied
for all the but it seems your attitude
to criticism is that you should take it
you should take it somewhere else this
is big knee of Geo broad your Justice
Minister compared the e use oversight to
Nazi Germany Nazi occupation of Poland I
would definitely definitely advocate for
for simply the same standards like for
instance if we if we see the situation
in
in Germany you were able in 25 years
years ago to mythologize for statements
like that well III think that in in the
context of different discussions
different statements I met are made but
at the end of the day it's it's about
equal treatment of all the member states
of the of the European Union but it's
also about listening to the legitimate
criticisms from the European Union when
you have signed up to the values of
European Union and accepted them if if
the criticism is legitimate I'm
welcoming this criticism because the
democracy and liberally liberal
democracy is all about being open to
criticism so as long as you like it it's
fine but if you don't like my criticism
if I don't like it it's legitimate
criticism as well all I advocate for
it's also a very equal treatment like
for instance if if in Germany a year ago
in curl that there was there were some
events which were really not appearing
on the surface because all the media
treated this as a taboo it was not there
was not criticize this was not
criticized by the by the European Union
and European Commission but it was
criticized widely in Germany itself so
the Commission demands many weeks after
many weeks after after after it happened
but you accept the right of the European
Union to say what it feels is really
necessary be more what they were pretty
consistent in their belief that the rule
of law or the situation they got it over
yesterday dick they completely
misunderstood us my son Richard as well
let's let's start with the
Constitutional Tribunal in in the in the
Netherlands in Switzerland in Luxembourg
there's no Constitutional Tribunal and
there is a law which does not allow the
judges to judge - - to decide on the on
the legislation made
by the Parliament so why if this is
alright why does the outgoing president
of your Constitutional Court say the aim
of the legislation that you've
introduced is to destroy the court and
to create a kind of private counsel for
our beloved leader I think he means mr.
Kaczynski partly this is a very very
interesting persona because he's in fact
a politician is he is not he was not
only a chairman of the Constitutional
Tribunal he was a politician who tried
to support their leaders to understand
what is happening in Poland we have to
make one statement for the first time
over the last 27 years or not for the
fibrils but for the first time so
strongly the Vox Populi so the a very
strong voting in favor of some of
different solution solutions has been
made and all the established parties all
the political establishment and economic
establishment and also judicial
establishment which was not changed in
at the beginning of 90s they are
defending the ancien régime areas it's
one thing Minister just to reject the
criticism from abroad but your own
Ombudsman who is charged under the
Constitution for protecting rights and
freedoms in this country to paralyze the
Constitutional Court so you have
convinced him either in the fighting for
the previous establishment you perfect
state law at all if you asked anybody
who really understands Polish police the
politics if um if Ombudsman is
politically tainted or not 99% would be
would be telling you of course he is
from the previous establishment of
gives completely left-wing so it from
such a person so all these are
agreements all these arguments against
the government you dismiss because
they're politically tainted if we talk
openly and if we talk scenery rights to
do of course we can we can understand
all sorts of different criticism I'm
just telling you did it to understand
the situation in Poland we one can
imagine that there was this post
communist era frozen for 25 years and
now this storm one drank parrillada
started in in Poland and this and this
is a completely different approach to
many issues like to institutions
institutions let's look at let's look at
the court and the and the issues
surrounding the court because on the one
hand you say everything is fine with the
court but we have a tribunal a president
tribunal president elected by what the
EU considers a questionable procedure
another judge elected on a legal basis
that's found to be unconstitutional a
challenge to the election of three
sitting judges seven years after that
election so why not European Commission
so loud and vocal in the summer of 2015
when all the political parties which
were ruling but back then we're electing
judges which completely in an unlawful
way
well they silent what they are now but
we are asking were they were they were
silent they just one and a half years
ago when such a drastic breach of the of
the law ha happened but you reject that
as well
Minister you the net largest net
recipient of EU funds you get
exercisable some money something like a
hundred billion has been promised
between 2014 up to 2020 you and other
members in Eastern Europe were given a
pretty
blunt warning by the French president
the other day who said Europe isn't a
cashbox so the self-service restaurant
you're where you come and take what you
need we take your structural funds or
get access to the internal market and
then show no solidarity at all French
French president presidents are known
sometimes for very strong words I
remember Jacques Chirac into just bear
with me for two seconds
Jack's react saying in 2004 that or 2003
that we lost our opportunity to be
silent we in the Central Europe so this
is not equal treatment and not level
playing here I would say in the Treaty
of Rome we had those four famous
freedoms freedom to the provide services
movement of migrant workers movement of
capital and goods and three of them are
working very very well three of them
which are working in favor of richer
countries goods capital and people and
the last one which could work very much
in favor of the Central European
countries it's maybe 20 percent working
the freedom to provide services so I
would say that we have to really rethink
what was was was not implemented
okay about a rethink you're demanding
basic changes to the EU itself your
structure its decision-making process
your leader mr. krichinsky said he
wanted to see a new EU treaty these are
a lot of demands but the fact is you're
among the loudest critics you and the
Hungarians
no no your your model for change is that
of the self-declared a liberal democracy
Hungary isn't it because last September
your last September your party leader
mr. krichinsky said we are learning from
Viktor Orban the Prime Minister we are
learning from his example what Hungary
has done they have done lots of good
things to bring the new balance because
it was completely tilted towards selling
all the assets to foreign companies and
and the ownership in
economy after 25 years of transformation
was in nineteen ninety percent enhancer
foreigners so Viktor Orban is trying to
bring some more balance into this doctor
what Hungary has done is get itself
condemned by a dozen countries last year
in the UN's peer review process for
among other things increasing hostility
towards the media and civil society and
intimidation and reprisals against
government critics and and you seem to
like that no no no no you seem to like
that answer in a following way what's
the percentage of media in Poland or in
Hungary I don't know it's precisely the
situation in Hungary five years ago a
buddy in Poland in the hands of only one
group I can I can answer this question
95% is this balanced media approach is
it a balanced media right when you
freeze out or fire journalists from the
public media 2002 importance with for
the 29 percent or maybe 25 percent of
what our predecessors done why were you
not asking our predecessors those
questions eight years ago or 15 years
ago
why were you happy with post communism
post communist governments and are you
not so happy I think that we have to all
rethink our relationship because we are
now it produces a surprise for you in
turn International Monetary Fund and the
World Bank when I was visiting there for
a couple of II in today they were very
much in favor of our responsible
development plan because it is bringing
social inclusion it is addressing
inequalities in Poland we we were going
too much into oligarchy he was this the
right direction view not shared by the
try a movie that monitors compliance
with your signature on the International
Covenant for Civil and Political Rights
no no we were asking those body to come
to us like the Venus
Commission but criticized your moves on
the Constitution at the same time
significant significant part of this was
implemented so we we are on the same
hymn sheet or very close to each other
right now why not to take into account
those huge international institutions
like IMF and the World Bank which were
praising us for what we've done in terms
of social environment you don't get a
lot of praise Minister for your attitude
to to migrants the Ombudsman mr. bottner
who you say it's politically tainted
spoke in October about quite open hatred
towards migrants and refugees in public
life harassment physical attacks hate
crimes towards my he must be kidding and
she was saying shows from the pub when I
compared what was happening in in terms
of Poland comparing to German or
comparing to France in terms of hatred
or hate crimes in the United Kingdom
against poles or some other sea citizens
this is completely different picture in
our situation we are accommodating
hundreds of thousands of refugees from
Ukraine from the war areas of Ukraine in
in eastern part of the you have an
organization called never again
Association which tracks racist and
xenophobic incidents they say they used
to record between five and ten such
incidents a week now they're recording
that many in a single day recently they
say we've had problems keeping up with
and gathering and registering all the
information we get because there is so
little of it and do you know how many of
them they are recorded in Germany and in
France I thought about all this relative
you had a compare if you ask in Brazil
it would be probably daily hundreds or
thousands if there are fighters the
reaction of your government to what is
going on there was to shut down the main
body for preventing such incidents
incidents
April last year you closed the council
for the prevention of racial
discrimination xenophobia and related
intolerance you did that without
providing another body to take its place
why in if you're taking
event see all scheme of things we are
taking this very seriously because what
brings a security to the country is is
the quality of your police is the
quality of your services special
services and so on and and given all the
recent polls the level of security in
the society increased people feel more
secure and in Germany in France in Italy
people feel less secure why is this so
the tens of thousands we've seen
marching on the streets of Warsaw to
protest one or other of your panels
which they feel more secure which is
which is which is the sign of your
mother's here the threat no no no here
is again you're not so objective
treatment three years ago you know what
the demonstrations were on the street of
war so hundreds of thousands of people
you have not hardly you'll have hardly
noticed them today there are tens of
thousands you are right every now and
again I have not seen them by the way
for the last six months but maybe there
will be another demonstration which is a
sign of democracy working in Poland the
UN ministers also criticized your
party's attitude to migrants and express
concern what it could statements by
state authorities in which they refuse
to accept refugees of the Muslim faith
we are accepting actually lots of
immigrants predominantly from lots of
refugees migrant workers is the one
thing but actually tens of thousands if
not hundreds of thousands for our
refugees from from Ukraine so later in
2000 we believe that Europe has its
borders at the very south there is a
pressure from North Africa in Greece or
in Bulgaria there is pressure from
Middle East but you don't want Muslims
you specifically said Muslim we do
accept the agency says Muslim refugees
with threatened Poland's
we we do accept lots of Muslim Muslims
as well but not as many as us as in
Germany because you are much richer
countries because you didn't have 50
years of communism so why did the
Vatican before the Pope's visit here
year issue a statement criticizing what
occurred and artificially created fear
of Muslims in Parliament why did the
Vatican feel necessary to talk to you
like that
I don't know I I think this is one of
the most secure countries remember World
Youth Day with Pope Francis actually
with Vatican presence here millions of
people in Poland and zero accidents zero
crime this is the proof in the eating of
evil even the Pope himself to remind you
in Krakow see reminded you a merciful
heart opens up to welcome refugees which
we are doing hundreds of thousands to
destroy government said in March last
year I say very clearly that I see no
possibility at this time of immigrants
coming to Poland and they are coming in
hundred she says if she say we have
registered 1 million you create 1.3 what
in one context 23rd a month probably if
you quite importing according cried but
this is in the context and I'm telling
you the whole context the whole context
was that over the last 12 months we've
accepted 1.2 million of immigrants out
of them
our guesstimate is one hundred to two
hundred thousand refugees from the war
areas this is our contribution to easing
the tensions in Europe isn't it is it
easing the tensions to try to introduce
tightening of restrictions on abortion
to trial that's a completely different
yes it is this is this part of the
European Union remit it's something that
people have expressed concern and you
see you see in the demonstrate you have
two paths one you have a bank give me 20
seconds give me 20 seconds at least okay
the government has not submitted any
legislation about this the Parliament
and the majority has not submitted any
legislation or what all what happened
was that one quite radical
ngo has submitted legislation and we
have promised before that if there is a
legislation based with at least 100,000
of signatures from our citizens we will
give it a go in the parliament so we
have done this it was not the project of
the government it was not the project of
the Parliament and it wasn't a project
of the government and we've stepped back
it was it wasn't the project of the
government to try to limit reporters
access inside Parliament access of media
yes it was a it was simple it was a
project from the from some part of the
majority party and we have step back we
have Assembly on the streets you know no
no it's already voted the first we see
it's another very good exact thank you
for this because it's another very good
example of misunderstanding
it's newsom to freedom of a senator
stood no no my invitation my education
to you is read more newspapers from both
sides
not only the liberal media early read
also the other media out yet at all
telepaths as does our Roman friends
2,000 years ago said which means the
freedom to offer something it's not
limited it's the opposite you know what
was the project about the project is
about saying you couldn't have a
demonstration you couldn't have a to the
message at the same time if there is a
completely demonstration if there's a
completely leftist demonstration in one
place for last couple of months we would
allow this demonstration to be forever
this was the project to create more
security at least two-thirds of the
population in Poland are buying human
which is my generations as well no no do
you remember demonstrations two and
three years ago on the September 11th
which is the Independence Day in in
Poland there were huge riots on the
streets during the times of our of our
predecessors why was that because three
or for demonstrations were meeting with
each other in one place and all the
changes which we wanted to implement in
the in the new legislation on assembly
was to separate them isn't it isn't that
the good move that's not what the the
your critics say they say I know they
say it's you it's you saying who can
demonstrate where and giving the
responsibility to central government and
taking it away really that's blame is
expressed this very very loudly
everybody can demonstrate whatever they
want
apart from Communists and nasty opinions
okay
everybody because this is the country
law communist and NaCI are crime
murderers we don't allow for for
demonstrations of that kind everything
else they can demonstrate wherever they
want provided that they are not clashing
with other demonstration minister you
think isn't law and justice party that's
that's that I'm a fresh member of life
you are a freshman 25 years in in the
business I think it was your father who
got up in November 2015 and said law is
important but law is not sacred
yeah good of the nation is above it so
you know and just this part it doesn't
accept the primacy of law no no I
exactly like like the famous German
lawyers who did if happier and and some
others they said that the positive is
most positive positive approach to law
has to end has to stop at some moment
because there you're saying some things
more important than the law of course of
course no change no change just ain't
life of people security dangerous wrote
I don't want I don't want to be going to
putting in abstracts no no okay so let
me be very conditioned let me let me be
very very precise not abstract as if
in Nazi Germany the law was very much
observed you know in Nazi Germany I'm
giving you an elastic example it's
really elect everything was under the
umbrella of law than in the 30s and in
the 40s and this law and and this is
what the Nazi Germans in the Nuremberg
you cannot stay we're actually defending
this was law this was actually we are
saying abstract this is not actually
still respect and only legal positive
possibility with respect the law of
course of course we do respect respect
the law is the law and justice law and
justice not only law justice is very
important your critics and it goes into
during the 25 years of the post
respondent transformation there was very
little justice and the very bad people
were hiding behind the law exactly what
your critics say thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]